award-winning chef and TV personality
Marcus Samuelsson says he's only
scratched the surface of immigrant
cooking here in the u.s. in season two
of his show no passport required he
brings attention to cuisines and
cultures of immigrant communities around
the country this season Samuelsson goes
to six American cities in this preview
of Monday's episode he travels to an
Armenian kebab restaurant I'm already
hungry in Los Angeles well your parents
both born in Armenia what they don't my
pears that born in Egypt Wow you know
off the second world they immigrated to
Armenia and what about you your pattern
hello my sin migrated from Armenia
[Laughter]
Marcus Samuelsson joins us first on CBS
this morning good morning welcome thank
you so much for having me
you are you're an immigrant yourself
we've told the story before but when you
go to all these places is anything about
the immigrant experience surprise you
you know what's amazing is that each one
has a story you know the immigrant story
of America it's not monolithic you know
and we need to hear it again and again
because it inspires us you know and food
is such a great way in such a delicious
way on learning about another culture
right like I cooked all my life but
through no passport required I was lucky
enough to have Nigerian food that wasn't
that familiar with or Armenian food in
Los Angeles and these amazing cities now
fall so these surprises I didn't know
that is the second biggest immigrant
community Seattle was Filipino for
example I didn't know that the West
African communities America is a nation
of immigrants of course it's true so I
guess we're a nation of immigrants who
does anything excluded from what could
be on the show no I mean as long as it's
delicious songs that's a story you know
I'll go there you know it's such a
privilege to also see America right like
you're going TT we're in all types of
cities all kinds of places and you start
to see when you read the menu some like
oh my god these are traditions
rituals are sometimes 2,000 years old in
in on Monday when the airs on PBS we're
in LA in Glendale and East Hollywood
with Armenia community Harry the but
through my guy which is really a curing
me you know the way he kills me they've
done that in this family alone each man
has been the streamer master for 300
years going back Wow coming to LA city
of dreams and setting up the same thing
I mean that's American to me and that's
very inspiring so many cities yeah oh
there are foodie tradition now I mean
they're there on the map now because of
immigrant cuisine I think of London I
think of San Francisco a large part but
why do you think that's the case well
because we all add something right and
sometimes you know immigration it really
and food sometimes it's a big war
sometimes it's a disaster one part of
the world but they're very very often
people still dream about coming to
America yeah and when you come into
America very often the first job the
first entry job can be through
hospitality right and maybe their vision
was for the kids to go to college well
guess what sometimes are hard to get a
job what we know how to cook we know how
to know take care of our culture and
cook for each other so the hospitality
industry it's very often the first entry
point and you know America's Betty Ford
there again you said Marcus you said
quickly a couple years ago and you were
here said there's a big false narrative
about immigrant work the immigrant work
ethic here in America has that change do
you think you know I first of all I
don't believe me to say that immigrants
are lazy nothing could be further from
the truth
immigrants worked really really hard
they're super proud to be Americans
first of all also they escaped three
wars four or five different countries to
get here they're probably just as a
patriotic as you and I are not maybe
even more Marcus Samuelsson thank you
very much for being here season two of
no passport required returns Monday on
PBS